Khloe Kardashian is pregnant that's just  really exciting for me  just days after news broke Kylie Jenner  is expecting a baby girl with Travis  Scott clove is pregnant with her first  child with boyfriend Tristan Thompson on  Tuesday Tristan seemingly responded to  the pregnancy news tweet encrypted eye  emojis Chloe and her NBA beau have been  dating since September 2016 after  meeting on a blind date talks of  starting a family together has played  out on Keeping Up with the Kardashians  he wants to have like five or six kids  with me and that's lovely we could start  at one and we could grow from there but  now like knowing I'm not on birth  control that's just like it's scary it's  like a really big step big says Kim is  also expecting her third child via  surrogate which means there will be  plenty of Kardashians to keep up with  for years to come  you